e ele eu sou péssima qualidade e assim a
zoeira cada um pode acabar marcada do
local onde da manhã em casa nada pela
outorga fixa de amanhã enquete todos não
tá tudo bem feito ele está sozinho outro
curta metragem dele quando multa metais
ou lançado você vai poder ir nesses
minutos aqui se você explicar a minha
mão caso você vive
[Risadas]
você tem criança doente
bike a partir da análise comportamental
que atende a volks curta metragem e
ajeitar a conexão e passa pela gente
algumas coisas acontecem de madrugada
mandar é fazer com que madrugada
assim que a mulher não tenha coisas
gostosas na linha toda a gente vai
comendo banana são de uma grande
caminhada em um carro era fiscal não é
técnico 5º lvii risco do estado longe da
gente aí no estádio e em mim tá com medo
nem outro no peito neve não há também a
gente perguntar se curta ele está
tentando não ficar muito truncado branco
acompanha a edição aqui ainda com gente
está com o trade eu tô aqui e já
enfrentei digão no cargo só tava no
mercado eo pior galera porque o pó você
pode pensar que o coração é o bem mais
importante do seu curso
você pode pensar também que o seu
cérebro forma importante é o povo agora
seu cultura acaba num sinal não tem
ninguém cada 600 lá não saiba porquê
porque o cookie mãe você com quem você
cai mas o trade seu eu e meu amigo na
hora certa e se eu fosse um big brother
e se eu fosse era três meses sem pagar
agora eu não carrego uma espada e não
marcava no cérebro e o canto tudo não é
só isso que é onde tudo é porque a gente
já vem relembrar que o ditado popular
que vaso que não é fácil parar no gol
entre a uefa
jô base de ferreira padre padre paraná 8
em pé numa fila ela já que o brasil não
minta cheio está com base na noite em pé
e design chega até nós de que não
aguentamos ficar sem comer de longe a
gente
o ensaio ele nós temos um caminho eu em
god is noni são crianças a caminho da
galera respeito deixando o campo é
sempre que o tema não é que eu vou para
um papel no filme o filme na amazônia
como fazer papel de muita não é isso
mesmo é isso aqui é só um videozinho da
madrugada muito obrigada a assistir é
dar liquidez e que se use da light
o meu deus é coisa que você não se você
não pode perder esse canal cíclica me
inscrever clicando em inscrever-se toda
vez que tivermos nosso time sempre
guardado no meu deus
a galera de diversidade que está aqui na
descrição do vídeo ao primeiro é você
vai ter de discussão de desconto se você
comprar alguma coisa lá conheci outra
coisa toda vez que meu filho saia jogar
redes sociais o twitter
aquela instagram e aqui é o meu facebook
e aqui na casa do bairro felicita o
canal dele você clica aqui para se
inscrever no canal do bairro é feito
dessa terra até a terra acaba de vazar
alguma coisa
nessa toada clinton
ela quer que quem manda é perto daquele
dia
aliás essa batalha acaba nessa desgraça